Sal: This is Sal Khan
here of the Khan Academy,
and we're going to do a really
fun experiment this morning.
We're on Google Hangouts on
air with Secretary Duncan,
Secretary Arne Duncan,
Secretary of Education,
and we're just going
to have a conversation
about technology, about
education, about higher education,
and I'll just hand it
over to Secretary Duncan.
Secretary Duncan: Well,
I hand it back to you
and take any questions you have;
but, just as you know, I'm
a big fan of your work.
My children have really enjoyed
participating in Khan Academy.
Lots of exciting things going on.
Obviously came off the bus tour
last night with the President,
we're really working hard
to reduce college costs.
But whether it's talking about
college costs, or technology,
or K to 12 reform, or try
and do more early childhood,
happy to take any questions you have.
And again, thanks so
much for the leadership
and the extraordinary
amount of opportunity
you're creating for children,
not just in this country,
but across the globe. It's
pretty amazing to see.
Sal: Oh, no, thank you.
That means a lot to hear from you,
and your children use Khan Academy?
Senator Duncan: They do use Khan Academy.
(both men laughing)
They actually enjoy it, I don't have
to beat them to make them do it.
Sal: [unintelligible]
enjoy it. That's great.
Senator Duncan: It's been fantastic.
Sal: So, the place I
really want to start on,
we get a lot of comments
here, especially because
a lot of the news with the bus
tour that ya'll have been making
around some of the announcements around
trying to reduce college education costs.
We got on Facebook and on
Twitter from Science Guy,
what element of the reform plan
do you think is going to be
the biggest game changer,
and who's saying there's [unintelligible].
They're all asking around this,
how are you going to address
the cost issue with this plan,
and do you think it's
actually going to happen?
It seemed like there was some resistance,
from at least comments,
from members of Congress.
Senator Duncan: Well, there's
always going to be resistance,
and change is hard, as you know.
But, let me just start with
sort of explaining the problem.
And I have to tell you,
virtually everywhere I go,
whether it's to the grocery store,
whether it's to the dry
cleaners, every plane I'm on,
you have hard-working middle
class parents coming up,
and it's almost heart-breaking,
basically pleading for help,
and college costs are just crushing folks;
and when you poll the American public,
it's pretty scary, a lot
of people started think
that college isn't for
them, it's for the wealthy,
it's for the rich, it's
for people not like them.
At a time when going to college
has never been more important,
unfortunately, it's never
been more expensive.
So, we have to work together
to drive down costs.
We have to have much greater transparency
and help young people and their
families make better choices.
We have to challenge states
to continue to invest;
we can't do it by ourselves.
We have to make sure
that young people have
a set of good options to select
from and know what a loan is.
What's a grant? What are graduation rates?
What are the particular strengths and
weaknesses of majors of different places?
But to see the President
so engaged, it's fantastic.
This is one simply where
we have to break through,
and this should not be political.
We want to lead the world
in college graduation rates.
Right now we're on a path in terms
escalating costs that is unsustainable,
so having a honest
conversation with the public,
how do we better encourage
states to do the right thing?
How do we better rank universities
and rank them based upon
are they taking in low income students?
Are they graduating? Are they
keeping down college costs?
There should be nothing
political about any of this.
I look forward to working
with, not just the public,
but with members that,
republicans and democrats,
in the House and Senate to do
the right thing for our country.
This to me, again, is
not just about helping
individuals and their families,
but really fighting for our
country's economic future
and to remain economically competitive.
We need to have the best
educated work force in the world,
and some form of higher
education has to be the goal
for every single young person; a high
school diploma is no longer enough.
4-year universities,
2-year community colleges,
trade, technical, vocational training,
that has to be the goal for everyone.
Families have to have the
security that they can,
if they work hard that they'll
have a chance to pursue that goal.
That's what this is about.
Sal: This is a kind of
over-arching theme of this plan,
especially around the rankings,
is to rank universities based on,
essentially, value that they create
or the economic opportunities
for students the afterwards,
so that the universities
that are really expensive
and the students aren't
getting good jobs afterwards,
they're going to be at
the bottom of the list
and might not get a grant
funding or subsidized loans.
Secretary Duncan: Well,
we're open to all of this,
and want to have a really
public conversation
over the next year and get the best ideas.
I'm always interested in
our universities improving.
Is there growth and gains?
Are graduation rates going up
or down, or are they stagnant?
Are serving more low income and first
generation Pell Grant recipients?
Are graduates being able to compete
successfully in the job market afterwards?
But there's a whole host of things.
I'm very aware that if you put
the wrong metrics out there
you can create some perverse incentives
and disincentives and
encourage bad behavior.
That's obviously the
last thing we want to do.
We want to be very thoughtful and
nuance and so no preconceived notions.
We're going to go out and talk
to professors and presidents
and parents and students themselves,
have a national conversation;
and at the back end of that,
come up with something
that makes more sense.
What many folks don't understand is today
we invest about $150 billion
each year in grants and loans.
This is a huge investment
that we make happily
that the tax payers support,
but all of that investment, Sal,
is based upon inputs, access to college.
None of it is on outcomes.
Are students actually graduating?
Are they graduating with
skills that will help them
be successful the rest of their life?
So, having a greater
emphasis not just on access,
which is important, but
really on the outcomes.
That's where we want to go.
Sal: Hm, that makes sense. Makes sense.
With some of the statements
that ya'll have been making,
we got a lot of tweets,
this is from Becky Bacala.
Ya'll talk a lot about also the
importance of technology in education,
and how technology might be a
tool to increase accessibility,
but it did raise some
concerns from several folks.
Becky Bacala wrote, "Some
students' only chance
"of carrying human
interactions are at school,
"why is online learning better?"
Erica Kirshner wrote, "Replacing
teachers with computers
"to save money only
short changes our kids."
Also wrote, "Technology must
work in concert with the teacher,
"it's not the teacher."
So, what are your thoughts?
There's a lot of fear around,
when people talk about technology,
and especially when
they're talking about it
in the context of cost-savings,
that it means that you're gonna
have fewer human beings involved.
Secretary Duncan: Yeah, I always think
there's false dichotomies, false debates.
Technology is never going
to replace great teachers,
and what all the research,
all the studies seem to show,
is that blended learning,
great teachers empowered
by great technology, is
what's leading to the best
educational outcomes
achievements for students.
As I travel the country and get to go
to hundreds and hundreds
of schools each year,
which I love, I'm seeing amazing teachers,
some young teachers, some 25
to 30 year veteran teachers,
who talk very openly with me about
their initial apprehension and fear
about using technology in classroom;
but how much more empowered they feel,
how much more effective they feel,
how much more engaged their
students are in their learning.
So, this is neither, this is
never going to be either or,
it's got to be both, and I
think technology can help
to strengthen teaching, help
teachers not just teach,
but actually know whether their
students are learning or not.
The goal is not to teach, the goal
is actually to have students learn,
to have students much more
engaged in their own learning,
to have parents know what's
working and what's not,
and have them be better partners.
I just see tremendous upsides; I
think there's a huge equity play here
to give students and communities
who have historically
not had the best of
education opportunities
to really level the playing field.
But, it's also a chance to
raise the bar at the high end.
If you can do both those things,
push equity very, very hard
and raise the bar for the country,
it's early, we're in our infancy.
You and others are helping
to lead this field,
but I'm actually extraordinarily
helpful about where this can go.
Sal: Completely agree with that.
What we've seen at Khan Academy is,
as you know, people a lot of times
have that knee jerking reaction,
"Oh, this is technology versus physical,"
but it's the exact opposite.
Secretary Duncan: Just to
give a couple quick examples.
The President and I, we
made the announcement
about increasing access to broadband.
We went to Moorseville, North Carolina;
this is a district that's
invested heavily in technology
over the past 6, 7, 8 years in tough
economic times, no additional money.
What they simply stopped
doing is buying text books.
I continue to wonder as a nation,
why we keep spending 7, 8,
9 billion dollars each year
on text books that are
literally out of date,
basically, the day you purchase them,
so they'd made that shift, and again,
veteran teachers feel that they're
teaching an entirely different level.
I've been to places like
School of One in New York,
where you have larger
classrooms, 30, 40 children
working in small groups, teachers
walking between different groups.
Again, veteran New York teachers,
initially very scared about this,
think they're changing kids'
lives in a really important way.
Again, early on, a lot to learn together,
but I'm very, very hopeful,
not just on the K to 12 side,
but in higher ed with [mooks] as well.
Sal: Absolutely, but
moving on in K through 12,
a lot of the questions we've gotten
have been around the
common core, in particular.
Nathan Nasby wrote, we've already
had standards at a state level,
"How is the common core
going to be different?"
We have several questions;
Deborah [Debara Lomeo] wrote that
in her state of New York, they're
already having issues with
graduation rates, what is the
common core going to do there?
I'll throw in my 2 cents
is at Khan Academy,
we're very focused on intentionally
creating material for the common core;
the thing that I see in it is it's
much deeper and much more rigorous,
so in that world, it's really a higher
standard than we've had in the past.
I guess, those are the 2 questions.
How will it improve overall
learning and graduation rates?
And is there a risk that
it's maybe too rigorous?
Secretary Duncan: These are all
great questions, important questions,
but let me be really clear.
One of the things I think has
hurt children in communities,
and ultimately our country tremendously,
is we had 50 different states
with 50 different standards,
and many of which got dummied down.
They got reduced to make
politicians look good.
We were actually lying
to children and families
telling them they are
prepared to be successful,
when frankly they weren't even close,
and to me that is absolutely
insidious, it is heart-breaking.
That's the worst thing
that can happen to a child
and to families that think they're on
track to being college and career ready,
and they get to senior year and find
out they're not even in the ball game.
They have no hope of doing that, and they
think they've played by all the rules,
and this has happened in
some places for far too long.
So, the idea of having high standards,
college and career ready standards
that are internationally bench marked
so we will no longer be lying to
students and families is a game changer.
Now, it's going to take a
tremendous amount of work
to help to prepare students, to
give teachers the PD they need,
the implementation of
this is going to be rocky,
and hard, and difficult, but I tell you,
every time you raise standards, students
do better, they're more engaged.
Sal, I'll argue, the vast
majority of students who drop out
don't drop out because
high school's too hard,
they drop out because
high school is boring.
They're not connected,
they're not engaged,
and your point, the chance to go deeper,
more critical thinking skills,
more analytical skills,
we think it's hugely important.
Teachers across the country
have really embraced this;
it is hard work, they know
they're taking on more.
We do a great job supporting
them, but I'm so hopeful
about where this is going to
go over the next 2, 3, 4 years.
If we can have the courage to
stay the course as a nation,
we will be at an entirely different place.
I can tell you literally for the
first time in our country's history,
a child in Massachusetts,
or a child in Maryland,
or a child in Mississippi, they're going
to be held to the same high standards.
As you know so well, young people
today aren't competing for jobs
in their district, or in
their state in their country;
they're competing for jobs
with children in India,
in China, in Singapore, in South Korea,
and I'm convinced our
children are as smart,
as talented, as creative as
entrepreneurialist children
anywhere in the world. We just have
to level the playing field for them.
We have to give them a chance,
and that's what this effort,
which is being led by
states on a voluntary basis,
that's what this is all about.
Sal: And following up on that,
we've gotten a lot of folks here
who, with the common core,
also express fear that this,
there's been a general trend,
more emphasis on testing,
and the fear is that with the common core
that seems like it's an even larger
emphasis on standards, possibly testing,
what's your view on this
balance between the very,
the objective things that
you can test in a test,
and whether it should be high-stakes or
not for things like teacher evaluation,
and the intangible skills, experiential
learning, things like that?
Secretary Duncan: Yeah, I think
these are really important issues
that we have to work through together,
but I will say part of
what I resented so much
about the No Child Left Behind Law,
and I lived on the other
side of it for 7 1/2 years
when I led the Chicago public schools,
and we wanted Congress
to fix the broken law.
Unfortunately, Congress
is pretty dysfunctional.
We provided waivers to 40 states,
so we're partnering very, very well
directly with states across
the political spectrum.
What No Child Left Behind
did, and I think it did lead
to an over-emphasis on a test,
on a proficiency cut score,
which I think is lots of
perverse incentives there,
lots of bad things for
kids and for educators,
what you're saying
through the waiver process
is states move in a very
different direction.
Yes, they're looking at
growth and gain improvement,
which I think should be part of multiple
measures of what you're looking at,
but they're moving way beyond
a focus on test scores.
They're looking at increasing graduation
rates, reducing drop-out rates.
Are more high school graduates actually
going on to some form of higher education?
Are they doing that not having
to take remedial classes?
I have to tell you so many
young people around the country,
40, 50% in some communities,
are taking remedial classes.
Okay, these are the graduates.
These are the ones that made
it through, they're not ready.
Are they persevering in higher ed?
So, what you're seeing in
terms of accountability
is moving way beyond a
focus on a test score,
which I think has lots of problems,
looking at much more long term outcomes.
I think that's a very, very healthy thing,
so we want common core to
continue in that trend,
but having states and
districts and schools
look not just at 3rd grade test score,
but again, are we
graduating more students?
Are they graduating prepared
to chase their dreams?
Again, be that in a world of
higher ed, or in a world of work,
on a much more holistic
sense of accountability
and comprehensive absolutely
right direction to go.
And states, again, I think are
showing tremendous leadership
encouraging creativity in these areas.
Sal: Yeah, absolutely, and another,
I guess, over-arching theme,
we got a lot of tweets
that touch on this issue
is that teachers themselves often are
feeling marginalized in the conversation,
they're feeling that everyone's
solution is sometimes to blame teachers,
and I think both you and I would
agree that education is literally the,
probably the most important investment
that we can make in society,
and often times there's lip
service to the importance of that,
and the lip service to the
importance of teachers,
but the way things are
structured right now
that they don't get paid what a doctor
or a lawyer or engineer gets paid.
They don't get, often
times, the same respect
that a doctor or an engineer gets.
What can we do to move
more in that direction?
Secretary Duncan: Let
me say a couple things.
First of all, anyone who's blaming
teachers is part of the problem,
not part of the solution;
teachers do extraordinarily
hard, complex, difficult
work every single day,
often without enough resources.
Again, i'm in hundreds
of schools each year,
and teachers are working amazingly hard.
Obviously literally just this week
you saw in DeKalb County in Georgia,
teachers and school members
prevented what could have been
just a horrific massacre and
just show tremendous courage;
I mean, literal heroes,
[profiles and courage].
The President and I talked to one
of those staff members last night,
Antoinette Huff, I talked to
the entire team this morning.
Teachers routinely go way,
way beyond the call of duty;
so, what we need to do
together is to elevate
and to strengthen the teaching profession,
to do everything we can to
attract and retain great talent.
We've put out a blueprint people can look
on our website to respect initiative.
We think it's again, the
best thing we can do.
I'll say 2 other things.
As a country, I think we're
just this fork in the road
of whether we see
education as an investment
as you and I do, and I would argue
the best investment we can make
or an expense, and every time
I go testify before Congress
we have a set of folks who say
we should cut back on education,
and cut back on head start, and
on K to 12, and on Pell Grants.
I just think that's very, very troubling,
and it's cutting off our
nose to spite our face.
Again, we want to have the best
educated country in the world,
and we have politicians
who refuse to invest.
It makes no sense. I worry
desperately, right now in real time,
about what's going on
the city of Philadelphia.
I worry about as the school year starts,
those children there who
deserve the best education,
receiving that inferior education
because folks refuse to invest.
North Carolina is a state
I worry tremendously about.
North Carolina used to be sort of national
leader in reform in so many things.
Teachers salaries have dropped
precipitously in North Carolina.
I spoke last week with
some teachers and it was,
these are fantastic
teachers in North Carolina.
Sal, it was actually heartbreaking,
you have teachers literally who
are making so little money now
that they were on food stamps.
They're receiving food stamps
to feed their children.
I spoke to another teacher
who was giving blood,
who was selling blood like
twice a month to pay the bills.
Again, for me, it just
makes no sense whatsoever;
so how we elevate the
profession, how we strengthen it.
I've already argued very
publicly that we should pay
starting teachers a heck
of a lot more money.
We should pay fantastic teachers
2 to 3 times as much money.
It is the best investment we can make.
Right now, as a country, in
too many states and localities,
folks, I think, don't
quite understated that,
and I would argue in tough economic times,
education's not something you cut back on.
You actually double down your investment.
We have to educate our
way to a better economy.
If you want more upper
mobility, more social ability,
the only way you do that is to
strengthen America's classrooms
and to support our nation's
fantastic teachers.
Sal: I 100% agree with you, I just,
it's scary, some of what
you just talked about.
I think a lot of, we definitely agree
that there has to be more investment.
There has to be ways to
compensate teachers better,
but at the same time, you have
these budgetary pressures,
so I just hope that these 2 things don't
run into each other with negative.
Secretary Duncan: Well,
what I would say, Sal,
is that these are tough
economic times, and yes,
there are budgetary
pressures, but I would say
budgets aren't numbers
on a piece of paper.
Budgets reflect our values.
The question I always ask, when, you know.
Hold us accountable at the federal level,
and you see the President's
tried to increase
investment at every level, early
childhood, K to 12, higher ed,
every single year; one of
the things I'm most proud of
is an additional $40
billion for Pell Grants,
serving almost 9 million, more than
9 million young people, Pell Grants.
But we can't do it by ourselves.
When states cut funding to education,
but keep increasing funding for prisons,
as many states do, they're
making a value judgement
that would prefer to lock people to up,
to incarcerate them, to
invest them at the front end.
so, yes, we all have, in our own families,
in our budgets,
professionally, personally,
we all have to make tough calls.
But the calls we make,
the investments we make,
reflect our values, and
I just desperately hope
more states and more communities
and more elected officials
at the national level, in
Congress, House, and Senate,
understand that we have
to invest in education,
that that means we have to
spend less on other things.
That might be a tough call,
but is the right call to make
for our children, for our families,
and ultimately for our country.
Sal: Yeah, and with that,
obviously we should be investing
in more education, and as we do, and we
do invest a reasonable amount already,
what's your view, and there's
a lot of talk now as something
that we get a lot of questions on,
and we talk about a lot of this,
is thinking about the structure
of education itself, that
the way that we teach,
and right now is really
something we inherited
from the 18th century [pressions]
where we group kids together,
and we move them at a set pace.
At least, to some of
what you talked about,
that kids get promoted because
they were in a chair for a year,
and then they get to
community college or college
and they're testing at
a 6th grade math level.
The other side of it is more
of a competency based model,
where students take as long as
they need to learn something,
but then they get to a very high standard,
and so, really that would make it
impossible that someone graduates
and has to take remedial math.
Do you see things shifting there?
Secretary Duncan: That they have to shift,
and we have to continue to accelerate.
The fact that we're still
teaching with a 19th century model
makes no sense whatsoever,
and 25 or 30 kids
sitting in rows all learning
the same thing at the same time,
same pace, again, it's
just like Neanderthal.
It makes no sense, and
so this idea, again,
with technology being
a great tool to empower
a moving from seat time, as you
said so clearly, to competency.
I don't want to know
how long you sat there,
I want to know do you know the material?
Do you know algebra or biology or physics
or chemistry, or whatever it might be?
If you know it, you
shouldn't have to sit there.
So, we're doing everything
we can to encourage this
on the K to 12 side, on the higher ed.
We're starting to do some pilots,
some experimental programs in places
like the University of
Southern New Hampshire
that is moving from seat time
to mastery to competency.
This is absolutely where we need to go.
What's still important for me, Sal,
is not just for the high flyers,
yes it's going to benefit the high flyers,
they need to be able to
move much more quickly,
but the average student should
be able to get the help they need
and that student who takes
more time, doesn't matter
how long it takes them to learn it,
they just need to master that content.
So, whether it's more time
during the school day,
more time after school, or
at night at home, and again,
using technology weekends,
the goal is to become
comfortable and confident
with whatever the material is
that whatever 3rd grade,
5th grade, AP physics.
This for me, is a game changer for kids.
It's absolutely the right thing to
do, and time should be variable.
Time should not be the constant.
The constant should be are students
having opportunities to learn,
to master the material, to be
engaged in their own learning?
So, again, there's some really creative,
innovative things starting to happen;
but, part of, I think,
our role is to take these
areas of innovations, these
pockets of excellence,
and try and share these best practices
and actually take them to scale
to make this the norm
rather than the exception.
Sal: Yeah, and just to
double underline that,
a lot of times what we see is, yes,
you have students go at their own pace
and the assumption is some kids
are just going to take longer
and fall further and further behind,
but we're seeing over and over again,
if you let students go at their own pace,
a lot of times that
student that you thought
was a a little bit slower,
they're taking their time
really filling in their
gaps, and they're becoming
the best student in the
class 6 months later.
Secretary Duncan: The
more you can articulate
those findings and demonstrate
them, that's so important.
Far too many adults underestimate
what students can do;
and yes, we know students need
help, we need to support them,
but our biggest problem,
I think, in this country
is not that we're pushing kids too hard,
it's that we're not
encouraging them enough.
We're not giving them enough
opportunities to learn and do more.
Whenever you raise standards,
ready to give opportunities,
you don't have more drop
outs, you have more graduates.
The problem, I guarantee
you, has always been
that we dummy things down
for kids, and they feel that,
they know it, they sense it.
They know that they think that we're
not serious about their education,
and they become disengaged, they back out.
We give them a chance to fly,
to learn, to empower them,
you see extraordinary things happen.
Again, not just for those at the top,
but those that we thought
may have been struggling,
let them find their passion,
let them find their interest
and they'll go to the moon with that.
We have to create those opportunities.
Sal: Another, I guess, over-arching theme,
it's along the same idea of
us going with a legacy system
that we've had since the [horseman]
brought us the [pression] system
in the mid 19th century, is
not only the system itself,
seat time versus competency,
but what is actually covered,
this is something I've written
about, a lot of people know,
is that this decision to
do algebra in 9th grade,
geometry in 10th grade, trigonometry,
the calculus and physics
in the senior year, and all of
that, that was decided essentially
by 10 men around 120 years ago.
So, one question I get, I
just [need] to have myself,
I love calculus, I've
made 400 videos on it,
I have it online. I love the subject.
Secretary Duncan: I need to watch
our videos. I need [unintelligible]
Sal: Oh, very exciting
stuff. But, at the same time,
the one thing I wonder is
something like statistics,
is are more applicable in pretty
much any field you go into,
but that's usually reserved for an
elective course in
college, and it isn't core;
things like law, you only get,
frankly, if you go to law school,
you don't even get it at
a undergraduate level.
Is there some movement to try to make
this more part of the core curriculum ?
Secretary Duncan: I always
talk about a well-rounded
world-class education, and so,
as all the things you mentioned,
it's computer science, which
obviously didn't exist 100 years ago.
Sal: I'm biased. I didn't
want to mention that people
talk about computer science (laughs).
Secretary Duncan: There are a lot
of great jobs in computer science
that are going on field today, coding, I-
Sal: [unintelligible] here.
Secretary Duncan: I would add
to that foreign languages.
I would add to that financial literacy.
I would add to that physical
education, recess, health;
and so, these are things
that generally you see
in the elite private schools, they
are this sort of part of core,
but somehow in public education,
again, often due to underfunding,
lack of investment, all those
things kind of get stripped away.
Again, I worry about, generally,
but very specifically, right now,
about places like
Philadelphia, North Carolina,
that I think are a sort
of a time in crisis.
When you take away those
kinds of opportunities,
our children should be growing
up bilingual and trilingual.
They have to be financially literate.
They have to have the computer
science and other things;
that has to be part of
the core curriculum.
So, yes, the basic reading and math
are fundamental and foundational,
but that's a starting
point, not an ending point.
Again, if we're serious
about keeping kids in school,
reducing drop out rates,
they're devastatingly high,
it's all of those things,
but I would add, it's more.
It's all the extra curriculars, it's
band, it's art, it's music, it's chess,
it's sports, it's academic
decathlon, it's yearbook,
it's theater, it's model UN, that
all has to be the norm as well.
Again, when we walk away from that,
we really, really hurt our children.
Sal: Yeah, I'd even go a little further,
but I actually think a lot of that stuff,
even if I think about my own education,
a lot of my real memories from
middle school and high school
where I felt I learned the most were
some of the things you just listed,
and it almost feels like there's
an opportunity to rethink
can these extra curriculars
become the curricular,
and that all the course goes
our ways to support that.
But I 100% agree with that.
With all of these, we've just
talked about a bunch of really,
I think, powerful ideas, and things
that are the correct direction,
but where do you see the
federal government in this?
As the Secretary of
Education, obviously education
is mainly executed on by the states,
how do ya'll try to influence what
happens in the right direction?
Secretary Duncan: So, again,
our goal is to lead the world
in college graduation rates;
that's the north star.
That's what the President's
challenged us to do.
One generation ago, we led the world.
We have flat-lined, we've stagnated.
About a dozen other
countries have passed us by,
and I think we're paying a real
price for that as a nation.
So, for me it's about
investing at every level.
It's increasing access to
early childhood education.
You and I haven't talked
about that this morning.
That's arguably the most
important investment
we can make is to get our
babies off to a good start;
let them enter kindergarten
ready to be successful.
We have to continue to
improve K to 12, drive reform,
increase graduation rates,
reduce drop-out rates,
make sure our high school graduates
are truly college and career ready.
Again, the big pusher making now,
is that some form of higher ed,
4-year universities,
2-year community colleges,
trade, technical, vocational training,
that has to be the goal for
every single young person today.
How we share best practices, how we
continue to encourage investment,
how we reward innovation and courage,
how we think about this comprehensively.
Again, really birth through
age, whatever, 22, 23, 24,
and even beyond; adult
learners coming back.
Community colleges
doing a great job there.
This, for me, is we're
fighting for our country here;
we're fighting for our families.
We want to provide as much leadership
as we can and drive this agenda,
but again, we need great partnership
at the state and local level, as well.
Sal: Right, and It sounds like
the way that ya'll execute,
obviously, ya'll have a
soap box, if you will.
People will listen based on
you can set the direction,
and on top of that, the Department
of Education goes out there
and really kind of rewards
districts and states that ya'll feel
are moving in the right direction.
Secretary Duncan: And we try
and invest, so historically
our department didn't invest
in early childhood education,
we thought that was our problem
with Congress' bipartisan support.
We've invested bout
$600 million to increase
early childhood opportunities
in states across the country.
That's a big deal; we would like
to invest dramatically more.
We want to make sure that
every child has access there.
We've saved a couple hundred
thousand teacher jobs
in tough economic times; we're
also driving reform K to 12.
Then, I said, on the higher ed side,
one of the things I'm most
proud of was a $40 billion
increase in Pell Grants, without
going back to tax payers for nickles.
We simply stopped subsidizing banks,
put all that money into Pell Grants.
That was wildly controversial
here in Washington.
We thought it was common sense.
We've gone from about 6 million
Pell recipients to 9.6 million.
But to be really clear, where
we started the conversation,
I'm very concerned that college
is becoming unaffordable,
not just in disadvantaged
communities, but for the middle class.
So, I'm proud of what we've done.
This is absolutely unfinished business,
and we have to push very, very hard
so that families have the security of
knowing if their children work hard,
they will have the chance
to pursue higher ed
once they graduate from high school.
Sal: And you did touch on
the early learning, which is,
I have a 4 year old and a 2 year old,
and they're in preschool
now, and I personally,
as a parent, have seen the
value of what's done for them,
[their] few years before they
go into the formal system.
Why do you think that
hasn't been more universal?
You know, Florida famously
has early childhood,
and that, you know, is kind of done
in a very bipartisan way
under Governor Jeb Bush,
but why don't we see that
more on a nationwide basis?
Secretary Duncan: I'll tell you why.
Because 2 and 3 and 4
year olds, your children,
don't vote, they don't [hire] lobbyists,
they don't have pacts, and I think,
too many politicians are wired to think
about their next election,
or just the next news cycle.
Early childhood education is the
ultimate in long-term investments,
and the dividends we often don't
see for a decade or 2, or 3, or 4.
But folks who are a lot smarter than me,
like James Heckman, the
Nobel Prize winning economist
at the University of
Chicago, has talked about
a 7 to 1 return on investment;
that every dollar we
put in early childhood,
we as a country get back
$7, less teenage pregnancy,
less crime, less incarceration,
more high school graduates,
more folks going to college, more
folks going into the workforce,
paying taxes, being productive citizens.
But it's a long-term play.
So, the President has put on
the table a $75 billion proposal
to dramatically expand
access to high quality,
early learning opportunities
around the country.
What's so interesting,
Sal, is at the state level,
this has absolutely
become a bipartisan issue.
You see great leadership by republican
and democratic governors who,
in tough economic times, are choosing
to invest; they are valuing this.
Quite frankly, our struggle now is to get
more of our republican
friends here in Washington
in the House and Senate to agree this
is the right long-term investment.
I'm working very hard behind the scenes,
and I'm hopeful in the
not-too-distant future
that we'll start to see a couple
of republicans join with us
to say this is the right
thing for our children,
for strengthening families,
and ultimately for our country.
Sal: Right, and going at the
other end of the spectrum,
where we talk about
college and graduation,
this is where we started our conversation.
The one thing that I hear a lot about is,
I hear this even from, sometimes
I talk, we partner with schools,
and they're like, "Hey, a lot
of our kids go to college."
then people, "Well, they should
be graduating from college,"
and we've talked about that today,
but it seems like even that
really isn't the real angle.
The real angle is are they being
productive and happy citizens,
and is some of what ya'll are talking
about also along that dimension,
it's not just, you
know, because obviously,
a college can graduate
everyone if it wants to,
it can lower its standards.
It's kind of what we talked about at
the state level with the standards,
how do you just make sure that it
doesn't happen, just window dressing?
Secretary Duncan: We
have to be very, again,
thoughtful and comprehensive;
and we're going to to go out
and travel the country and talk to
college presidents and faculty members,
again, and students themselves
and parents, and employers,
and get a sense of this, but
I think your bigger thing,
any time we're dumbing down standards,
whether it's higher ed, or
K to 12, early childhood,
any time we dummy down standards,
we're just doing a great disservice
to the folks we claim we're serving.
So, that's non-starter to begin with.
How do you make sure you have a high bar?
How do you make sure students
are engaged civically,
sort of in a participatory democracy?
How they're thinking about
giving back to the community?
What they're doing after
college graduation rates?
Yes, we need more STEM majors.
Yes, we need more computer science.
I was a very happy sociology major;
and we want, again, just let
people pursue their dreams,
whatever it might be, liberal
arts, it doesn't matter.
But we want them being in a position
to be successful once they graduate.
That, for me, is what we have
to be looking at, so long-term.
For me, it's not about salaries,
it's not about whatever.
Obviously, folks who go into education
don't do that to make $1,000,000,
they do it to make a difference.
But I want them going into education
prepared to be a great educator,
and if they can do that and be successful,
then I feel good about that.
If folks are unprepared
for the world of work,
whatever their dreams are, that's when
we have to challenge the status quo.
Sal: I completely agree.
If we have time, really
just for one final question,
so I'll make it a big picture question.
We're talking about a lot of things.
There are a lot of
exciting things going on,
there's technology, there's access.
Where you do think this is going to
go if we just dream a little bit?
If we look at the system 10 years
from now, 20 years from now,
is it going to look like
the system we have now?
Secretary Duncan: Quite frankly, I hope
it looks very different from the system
today (laughs), that we have today.
Because I just think we're not doing
enough, quite frankly, as a nation.
So, my hope, not even 10
years out, but 5 years out,
I'm impatient here, I don't want to wait.
I would love to see twice as many children
have access to high quality pre-K.
So, dramatically expand access there.
I would like to see almost
no classrooms of kids
sitting in rows of 25
and 30, and I want to see
students having a chance to learn
individually and work in small groups.
Again, using technology, moving
from seat time to competency.
That has to happen. I want
to see graduation rates.
They're actually at a 3 decade high,
which is encouraging, but we
still have a long way to go.
Graduation has to be the bare minimum.
If you drop out of high school today,
you're basically condemned to
poverty and social failure,
so we have to get those drop-out
rates down to 0 as fast as we can.
Then, ultimately, again,
high school graduates
have to be college and career ready,
but college has to be much
more accessible and affordable.
So, if we can really drive
down the cost of college,
not just a couple percent, but
significantly so that that dream,
that aspiration, becomes a reality;
families have that security.
It is clearly an ambitious agenda,
but I frankly think we have to move
on all those fronts simultaneously,
and move as fast as we
can, and move, again,
regardless of politics or ideology,
I could care less in that,
we just want to help our country,
want to help our young people,
we want to strengthen our families.
We should be able to
work together on this.
This is our national mission.
Sal: That was a, completley agree.
Thank you, Secretary Duncan.
This was a real honor to be able
to chat with you this morning.
Secretary Duncan: You're
doing a great job.
You're going to be the next Oprah
when you're done with Khan Academy.
Thanks for the opportunity,
and thanks again,
your tremendous leadership, I'm a big fan.
Sal: Thank you.